How to Train Your Dragon Toy Story 3 and
now what's this movie called again
Despicable Me alright so after How to
Train Your Dragon in Toy Story 3 were
the best movies in recent months I was
starting to wonder if there was
something wrong with me do I just like
kids movies now that are gone soft but
thankfully I can tell you that in my
humble opinion not all 3d cgi movies are
good I mean honestly comparing
Despicable Me 2 Toy Story 3 or even How
to Train Your Dragon it's kind of like
comparing Crash Bandicoot to Mario it's
just not the same caliber so despicable
means the story of a villain who kind of
looks like the penguin from Batman
Returns he's kind of in a rut he's
trying to get back on top so he needs to
pull off the greatest heist like ever so
he has to adopt these three kids to do
it they're all girls that's not creepy
it's you right now you're thinking all
right it could be like The Incredibles
but from a villains perspective and it
could have heart don't don't
and honestly I don't even think the
movie knows what it wants to be about I
mean is it about a villain rivalry
between the main villain and another
villain who looks like Bill Gates a
villain trying to steal the moon a
villain who adopts three kids and grills
a heart or a long and mostly boring
family movie with some funny parts
wedged in but ultimately it is all of
those mostly the last one
I mean movies are supposed to have
layers and subplots I get that otherwise
we'll just have one linear movie but all
the elements are supposed to mix well
and seem like they're all part of one
thing this one does not I mean this
movie kind of feels like what would
happen if you put ice cream on a steak
and topped it with guacamole great
elements did not work well together I
thought as little minions would be funny
but about the ninth time one punched
another one
it just felt old I felt like a
second-rate Three Stooges episode the
CGI version featuring a walks on chemo
who just punch each other that is the
joke that they do they punch each other
honestly there's just not much else to
say about the movie the elements didn't
mix and I think kids are gonna fall
asleep in this movie besides there are
better family movies out there in
theaters right now I mean it does have a
couple of touching moments and funny
parts I'll give the movie that but
they're enjoyable moments in everything
like the dentist's office you know you
like it when he gives you a sucker but
is it worth it ever all in all I guess
I'm kind of pissed because literally all
the good parts are in the trailer so
just watch that and save yourself the
time although that roller coaster scene
it's in the trailer does look really
good in 3d 15 dollars a ticket good
probably not I'll go to a real theme
park and ride a real roller coaster
however this movie does live up to its
name you know Despicable it
and if you like what you've seen here
even though I think this is my shortest
review I've ever done it's just not much
to say and you want to see more than
click right here to see more